foreign
North Carolina hi Jonathan how are you
hey how's it going today guys better
than we deserve what's up
absolutely so I've had a tough couple
months I got laid off but the light is
at the end of the tunnel and I got hired
last week
better job
I almost doubled my salary whoa thank
God you got laid off
exactly so that's what I'm doing I'm
trying to make sure that I'm doing
what's best and what's right with that
and I haven't followed your baby steps
to a t always and well it's time to
start Jonathan exactly and uh exactly so
that's where I want to make sure I'm
starting this job and get the paycheck
the first month I want to make sure that
I'm doing this right from now on good I
have uh 87 000 in student loan debt
and I have uh 27 000 left on my car uh
and otherwise I have no debt I have 8
000 in savings
um after I pay this the rent at the
first of the month I I have 11 and a
half but after I pay rent and everything
at the first of the month I'll have
eight thousand dollars in savings so I
have step one I need to build my way
back to step three thank the Lord I had
it there during the layoffs and
um I still have 24 000 in my Roth
um 401K good good and what's the new
salary how much are you making the new
salary is one uh 130. wow are you
married
I am not okay cool good for you all
right so 114 000 in debt eight thousand
dollars in savings
and 130 000 income did I miss something
nope okay
well it's it's simple and it's hard
because you're used to having that
cushion of an emergency fund while being
very unsafe and insecure on the debt
side and so babe you're in baby step two
you keep saying I gotta get back to baby
step three you were never there we got
to step in between that we just skipped
we just leapfrogged it
you can't get the baby step three unless
you've done two that's kind of how the
numeral numerology thing works so
um yes so so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna attack the debts
and your car is your smallest one and
we're gonna throw seven of your 8 000 at
that and you're maybe step one one
thousand dollars save now we're
attacking doing the debt snowballing
baby step two attacking with a Vengeance
and we're gonna you know do nothing
no eating out no partying no vacations
no spending money
I'm tired of renting I don't care you
really need to get this mess cleaned up
okay you're broke
that's why you're a runner
yeah so let's not be broke anymore let's
get this mess cleaned up so you got a
hundred and fourteen thousand dollars if
you pay off uh sixty five thousand
dollars a year
seventy thousand dollars a year out of
your 130 your debt free in two years
zero debt at all you have a paid for car
and Sally May will have been evicted
from your house
you'll have your life back how old are
you
30. okay or you can wander along the
next 10 years and be mediocre Jonathan
and at 40 still be screwing around with
the student loan debt like most people
do or you can punch the thing in the
freaking face repeatedly until it dies
El time to get with it are those student
loans broken up into a bunch of little
loans
um they Consolidated uh but they're
still like consolidated federally and I
think the average on that uh interest
rate is like 5.8 yeah so no adding to
your retirement no life for the next 18
to 24 months and don't withdraw from
your retirement either yeah 18 to 24
months it's game on it's I am so pissed
I am getting this mess cleaned up I felt
very vulnerable and Afraid when I got
laid off and I had 114 000 in debt so
the next time something bad happens not
if when something bad happens I'll have
no debt
it's a different feeling dude
yeah but not having I mean I because I
didn't attack my dad so hard I had that
three months you know safety cushion so
when the rain happened I was okay yeah I
kind of want to have that so you know I
kind of don't care what you want you're
broke
yep you call me
don't do this stuff I'm gonna be mean to
you do it come on I'm your coach it's
halftime all right okay yeah first first
half in in the first half quarter first
quarter you you got a little bit ahead
second half you got behind and now
you're coming in from the half and it's
time to get with it and let's get this
thing knocked out you get a new lease on
life you got double your you got thank
God you got laid off you got double your
income and no listen I don't want you to
stay with no emergency fund for long the
faster you get out of debt the faster
you're going to have a legitimate
emergency fund that's baby step three
but but listen this millions of people
have done what I'm asking you to do for
you doesn't affect me man but listen
don't don't sit and argue with your
personal trainer when he's got a
six-pack and you have a keg don't argue
with your personal trainer you called us
do it do it do it do it do it do it you
can do it man I'm cheering you on I'm
not fussing at you you can do this hang
on here's the other part the the student
loan pause is really what saved him and
that's coming to an end abrupt Halt and
so those payments are coming back and so
use another job you owe with many
payments is 87 000 makes up so next time
that happens you're not safe and that
emergency fund is going to get drained
real quick if we don't get rid of these
payments they're killing you man yeah
it's your shortest distance to peace
Financial Peace two words that don't go
together like Airline service okay it's
your shortest distance to peace and your
shortest distance to wealth the the
distance the path we're giving you
please the lady just called right before
you and said how how wonderfully it
worked when she finally decided to work
it so that's tough people go well Dave
I'm kind of doing your plan and I got no
debt except for a hundred thousand I'm
like are you listening to yourself like
did you just follow the plan if it
doesn't work come back and yell this
back later and narrow it sounds but you
can't do half the plan and get mad when
you get half the results don't call us
back baby here's the problem George you
don't even get half the results because
this thing doesn't it's not linear like
that doing half the plan gives you 10 of
the results
that's what the problem with ish is it's
more damaging than it sounds because you
feel like you're doing something yeah
ish you know but you're not really doing
anything it's like you know you're gonna
it's like the people that do yo-yo
dieting you know you know what I'm
talking about they lose weight and then
they gain back back and forth back and
then they lose weight and then they gain
back more and so the net five years
later is because they weigh more than
when they started considerably and so
because they didn't change permanently
the grooves in our brain when it comes
to the dieting people always say
lifestyle you've changed your lifestyle
well that's what we're talking about
Paradigm Shift behavior all of it now
the whole thing so hang on dude we're
going to send you a copy of the book The
Total Money Makeover I want you to get a
highlighter I want there to be like hand
grease on that book because you're
looking at it all the time lots of
sticky notes all through it this is your
guide it is a proven plan 10 million of
these Total Money Makeover books out
there
it didn't happen because it didn't work
those sales happen because this crap
works I don't know how to do nothing
else but dude I got this down hang on
we'll give you a copy of the book this
is the Ramsay show